Châu chính thân bày, bị bán nhân tình tình tình quan hợp báo,
về vụ nghiệm môi môn tóan bất thường tại trường Trung Hoặc của Thông Truyền Tuyền Quang.
Vụ vệnh ngay tru ý sau khi điểm thí tốt nghiệp Trung Hoặc của Thông năm 2018,
không trạm hai mình sảo được cơm bố.
Trong bá trạm hai mình tạm thí sinh của trường, hơn 2-3 chiến mê em đã từ chính điểm tóan trở lên,
trong đó hơn 1-3 bố mới bài thí đặt điểm mời.
Công ăn đã khởi tối vụ an và muốn bị cân để điều tra tội lợd giống chức buộc quyền hạn trong khi thi hành công buộc.
Trong số này có ông quyền hạn dưới, giáo viên toán trường Trung Hoặc của Thông Truyền Tuyền Quang,
thưa kiến tại điểm thí và bà trần tị thu hàng, trường điểm thí hiệu phó trường Trung Hoặc của Thông quyền bàn quyền,
dân tính hai bị cân còn lại trên được công bố.
Lên quan đến vụ việc đại diện sở giáo dụ và đảo tuyên quan cho biết,
và trong 2-3 thí sinh đều thống nhất định ý tối trước thí lại một toán.
Tối chính thống bài bộ giáo dụ và đảo tạo cho biết chưa chốt từ ngắn thí lại,
để nghĩ tuyên quan tiếp tục sắc mạnh trước khi có định phương ăn sự ý phụ hợp.